what's going on guys this is rob and um
you know I I want to make a blogad II
video talking to you guys because as you
guys know back in the day you know those
of you guys who have been around for a
long time back in the day I used to do
like blogs every week or something like
that and talk and talk to you all and be
like hey what's up you know and just you
know just chit chat for a little bit and
of course periscopes kind of taken the
room taking the place of that you know
periscope is and for those of you guys
who don't know periscope is an
application that allows you to live
stream directly over your phone over
your mobile device and it's really cool
to see because people do it from around
the world of course the crazy Russian
people are live streaming themselves
jumping into frozen lakes in zero degree
weather whatever I like watching them do
it on periscope it's funny to me am I
the only one that thinks that like
sometimes Russians are just crazy people
like you know it's it's weird to me no
offense to anybody who's watching this
who's from Russia I love you guys but
nonetheless you know Russians just kind
of cracked me up a little bit but um
anyway so um so there's a few things I
want to talk about in this in this this
vlog ax t vlog of sorts the first thing
is um having the first things is next
week so this week on thursday i'm going
to be going to chicago for the chicago
entertainment expo next week actually
get back on like sunday i think i'm
starting on on tuesday actually take off
to go to some great big thing that Faust
Vinnie myself Sal like you know we're
all getting together for out on the west
coast but um you know we're sorting on
on monday tuesday and wednesday i think
it is joel is going to be uploading
three videos on to my channel and the
reason why I've wanted to do that is
because of course as you guys know Joel
is starting out you know with K patrol
he's launching his youtube channel he's
working his butt off and you know is I
was going through you know a thought
occurred to me back in the day for those
of you guys who remember this long ago
this is a long time ago back in my 2009
2008 2009 when the call of duty
community was first exploding first go
first blowing up there was a really
popular trend where youtubers in the
call of duty community would promote
other youtubers that would help them
grow they would help your channels grow
they would give them you know sometimes
it would do dual commentaries sometimes
they would have you know they would just
kind of you know give them a shout out
or something like that and with with
geek culture being what it is you know
what geek culture growing as fast as it
is and with a comic book community being
being as popular as it seems to be you
know here on YouTube I figured why not
do the same thing and so a while ago I
launched a series on my youtube channel
called called opportunity an opportunity
was a way for me to allow other
youtubers to upload content to my
channel you know the issue was that you
know those who were starting out you
know antelope maybe they were they were
so kind of you know figuring out what
they wanted to do we're still trying to
organize how they were structuring their
content but more often than not they
were literally just reading wikipedia
articles and and then you know recorded
the audio filling on a video and then
sitting it to me which is something that
I didn't really care for too much is you
know I think that kind of takes away
from the creative element of making
videos and so what I want to do is I
want to begin the process of just sort
of providing bumpers for people at the
beginning of my video and so you know
it'll be something like you know be sure
to check out you know the like the logo
patriot is a really good example you
know he he plays call of duty which you
guys probably don't care too much about
but his voice is better than mine by
leaps and bounds he's got the voice of
God I swear like it's it's insane to
listen to him talk it's it's pretty
amazing but um but I'm a huge fan of oil
patriot and following him for a long
time but I wanted to you know there was
a wanted to basically throw you know a
five-second bumper like if you guys
remember in some of my videos I would
say things like be sure to follow me on
twitter there you can you know talk
either you can you know I don't know
whatever and talk to me directly or
something like that no matter what it
was it I said but um you know I wanted
to do that kind of thing but give
channels different channels shout outs
you know and so that way I could you
know provide all different kinds of
opportunities you know for the beginning
of my channel if somebody has if
somebody releases a game that I enjoy I
can literally just provide a five-second
bummer be sure to check out this game
because I think it's cool or whatever
the case may be you know but I also want
to incorporate you know youtube channels
from the community out there in in the
comic book world and so if you guys have
come on bug YouTube channels that you're
trying to grow
if you are doing reviews or something
along those lines and you're trying to
get your name out there um then send me
like a tweet you know follow me on
Twitter and instant me a tweet you know
or something along those lines and say
like you know you know here's here's my
bumper submission which is a perfectly
you know I'll understand what you mean
if you say that here's my bumper
submission I will understand what it is
that you're referring to and I won't
doesn't sort of mean I'll catch them all
just because I get so many tweets in the
day but um I'll do my best to catch as
many as I can and if this proves to be
something that I think is is cool if it
proves to be an idea that I like then
what I'll probably do is set up a second
separate email address and a lot of
people to simply just submit their
submissions there that way there won't
be any kind of influx besides you know
those bumper submissions and I'll be
able to just go through and do a bumper
on each one that I think is good now
having said that there are a couple
things going on um but because of the
fact that i'm not going to be uploading
videos from other Creators directly to
my channel you know i'm i don't really
you know it doesn't really concern me
exactly how it is that you present your
videos the issue is this in the realm of
youtube your videos have to be
interesting and captivating and have to
bring people and they have to have a
reason to people have a room to
subscribe you know um and so keep that
in mind you know when you're creating
your content but but nonetheless you
know with i think it's kind of a cool
idea you don't let me know you know how
you guys feel about that kind of thing
because in the end of the day I think a
in expanding camera but community is
great overall because it provides a lot
of different you know a lot of different
I you know I guess it provides a lot of
room for discussion it's the best way I
can think of it you know it provides a
lot of room for four talk and so on and
so forth and will it just you know
there's a lot of different people with a
lot of different views on comic books
and you know maybe somebody does a
review on I couldn't look that and we
heard it before and I'm like that would
make a really good you know how much
explain video or something along those
lines and just kind of go from there but
um you know another thing is uh what
else was it oh yeah um so Chicago but so
being in Chicago for the Chicago
entertainment expo I'll probably send
out tweets and things letting people
know where I'm at I don't know if
anybody will actually want to hang out
anything along those lines but i think i
get there thursday morning and then by
thursday afternoon i'll probably hitting
up different bars and stuff like that
just kind of a sampling the fair in
chicago in terms of where they have and
you know in the world of you know drinks
and pubs and so on and so what I'm
really excited to be there for st.
Patrick's Day weekend but um but yeah so
I think that about covers it um you know
there's not too much else I don't think
I just kind of wanted to throw that out
there and and let people know what's
going on so anyway guys I'm gonna go
ahead and bounce off here but I figured
I'd let everybody know what's happening
and yeah so I never I'm never really
good attending these videos so i guess
i'll just say i will catch you guys
later please